>> I'M LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS
IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT, RUNNING ON
EMPTY, THAT IS TO FOCUS ON
TONIGHT ANGLE.
I ONCE TORY CARTER OUR EYE OUT
TODAY, AND REVEALED HOW WEAK THE
DEMOCRATS POLITICAL POSITION
REALLY IS.
NBC NEWS IS REPORTING THAT BIDEN
ALLIES PLOT 2024 STRATEGY FOCUS
ON TRUNK.
EVEN IF HE FADES AWAY.
OKAY HERE'S A LITTLE PART FROM
IT, LAISSEZ IS RON DeSANTIS
AND KNOTTS TRUMP IS A REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE THAT'S WHAT I THINK HAS
BEEN A LONG TIME FOR THE
FUND-RAISER, I DON'T THINK IT'S
A HEAVY LIFT TO MAKE DeSANTIS,
AND TO BUT OKAY, LET'S GET THIS
STRAIGHT -- THE DEMOCRATS ARE
NOTHING TO TALK ABOUT BIDEN'S
GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT ARE
IN ANY DAN SHARP HOW ABOUT
THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT.
AND THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE
SUCCESSES AT THE BORDER BECAUSE
THERE ARE NONE, OR HOW CRIME IS
GONE DOWN BECAUSE IT HAS NOT.
SO INSTEAD, THEY CANNOT TALK
ABOUT HOW DEMOCRACIES AT RISK.
FASCISTS ARE ON EVERY CORNER,
JANUARY 6, IN CHARLOTTESVILLE.
AND OF COURSE, CHUCK TRUMP'S
TROUSSEAU CHOSE POST ABOUT THE
REVERSE OF THE 2010 ELECTION.
NOW OF COURSE C.H.O.P. IS
ADAMANT THAT HE NEVER SAID AND
HE DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
CONSTITUTION SHOULD BE SUSPENDED
OR TERMINATED.
BUT HIS POSTING WAS NOT WISE.
AND UNNECESSARY BECAUSE HE GIVES
A POP FATHER TO HIS POLITICAL
ENEMIES OF BOTH DISPARITIES, BUT
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO KNOW WHAT
TRENT THINKS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION, LOOK AT THE JUDGES
IS PUT ON THE FEDERAL BENCH.
THEY ARE JURORS WHO BRING IN
ALLEGEDLY PHILOSOPHY TO THE
CASES.
SO WHAT REPUBLICAN SHOULD TAKE
FROM ALL THIS, IS HOW EMPTY THE
DEMOCRATS 2024 BASKET REALLY IS.
WHAT ARE THEY HAVE TO RUN ON?
WELL COURTESY OF DIVIDED
INFLATION, REAL WAGES ARE DOWN,
HOUSEHOLD WEALTH IS DOWN,
SKY-HIGH FOOD AND ENERGY COSTS
ARE DRAGGING EVERYTHING DOWN.
IN THE RECESSION IS RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER, OR IT'S ALREADY
HERE, AND THE WIND THE UKRAINE,
THAT IS A DRAIN ON OUR TAXPAYERS
AND THAT IS NOT GOING WELL.
OH AND BY NAME OR NAMES
PERSONALLY VERY UNPOPULAR.
THAT IS THE CHECKLIST BY THE
WAY.
SO, ON AND ON AND ON.
THIS IS BAD NEWS FOR THEM.
SO WHAT NEXT?
THEY CANNOT WANT ON ANY OF THIS.
NONETHELESS, DR. JILL IS
REPORTEDLY FEELING LIKE HER
HUSBAND HAS THE WIND ON HIS BACK
FOR 2024.
WHO CARES IF HE SO FRAIL, IT'S
GONNA BLOW OVER THE WIND, BUT
SURE JILL MAY BE 83 RIGHT AFTER
ELECTION DAY BUT AS LONG AS THE
MEDIA KEEPS PROTECTING HIM WHY
WOULD HE RUN AGAIN?
WELL, IT'S A TOUGH SPOT IS IN IT
FOR THE DEMOCRATS THE SMART ONES
AMONG THEM, NO THAT THEY ARE IN
A BOX.
>> BIDEN JUST TURNED 80 YEARS
OLD, THERE ARE MANY DEMOCRATS
WHO THINK HE SHOULD NOT RUN FOR
SECOND TERM LIKE A NEW
GENERATION WILL BE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO COMBAT A
DONALD TRUMP IS A REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE, --
>> AND MOST VOTERS, THEY DID
NOT WANT CHILDREN.
THEY THINK HE'S TOO OLD.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE ENERGY.
THEN AGAIN, IF HE DOESN'T RUN
AND WHO ELSE DID THEY REALLY
HAVE TO RUN?
I MEAN NOBODY THINKS, A LOT IS
UP TO RUNNING THINGS -- WILL
HAVE A DISQUALIFIES HER.
BUT THEN THERE'S
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM.
HE IS REALLY THE ONLY GUY THEY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ITSELF IS IN
A MESS.
REMEMBER IT IS LOSING POPULATION
NOT A GOOD TREND.
AND IT TURNS OUT THAT PEOPLE
REALLY DO NOT WANT TO PAY
EXORBITANT TAXES ONLY TO WAKE UP
TO THE GUY INJECTING HEROIN ON
THE FRONT PORCH.
>> GET THEM OUT HERE -- AND
THEN YOU'RE KILLING THESE
KIDS -- IN THE KIDS CAN EVEN GO
TO SCHOOL WITHOUT SAYING ALL
THIS.
>> IS A HARD SELL.
AND NO, PETE PUT A JAY'S
HAPPENING EITHER.
HE KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
WHICH WOULD MAKE HIM A PERFECT
CANDIDATE TO BE PRESIDENT OF
YALE MAYBE.
AND YES, THERE IS ALWAYS
CORRECTION AND WITNESS WHAT MARV
WISH AGAIN AND GOVERNOR OF
ILLINOIS WHO BOTH JUST GOT
REELECTED AND POPULAR IN THE
HOME STATES.
BUT NEITHER HAS ANY NATIONAL
MAGIC YOU KNOW THAT I SEE THEM
PLAYING ALL THAT WELL IN THE
SOUTH OR THE PARTS OF THE
MIDWEST.
SO THEY HAVE IT, RIGHT NOW, AN
80-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO NEEDS
ASSISTANCE WALKING OFF THE
STAGE, IS THEIR BEST BET IN
2024.
NOW IMAGINE BEING THAT PARTY?
AND WITH THEIR LEAK 2024
STRATEGY SESSIONS, DEMOCRATS
HAVE REVEALED WHAT WE KNEW ALL
ALONG.
THAT THIS WAS NEVER ABOUT
GETTING RID OF CHUM, IT'S HIS
IDEAS AND POLICIES THAT THEY
FEARED.
FIRST BECAUSE THEY WERE, AND
SECOND BECAUSE THEY TAKE POWER
AWAY FROM WASHINGTON, GIVE IT
BACK TO THE PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THE POWER
RIGHT HERE IN D.C.
THEIR REAL TARGET IN WASHINGTON
IS THE OLD AMERICA.
THEY WANT THAT DISMANTLED.
BY TURNING OUR SCHOOLS INTO
FACTORIES FOR RACIAL AND
PROPAGANDA.
BY ATTACKING THE PRIMACY OF THE
NUCLEAR FAMILY ON MULTIPLE
FRONTS, AND BY REMAKING THE
COUNTRY WITH MILLIONS UPON
MILLIONS OF NEW ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, THAT THEY WELCOMING.
BY THE WAY, ANYONE WHO DISAGREES
WITH THEM, OR THEY JUST
PENETRATE LIKE THEY TREATED
TRUMP.
RON DeSANTIS, MIKE POMPEO,
EVEN MIKE PENCE LOOKOUT.
STAND IN DEFENSE OF GOD, FAMILY,
AND COUNTRY.
AND YOU ARE ON THE BLACKLIST.
NOW PARTY WITH IDEAS AND
CANDIDATES THAT INSPIRE AND
EXCITE IT DOESN'T NEED TENTACLE
STRATEGIES ARE SLASH AND BURN
TACTICS LIKE THIS, IF THEY
REALLY THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO CONVINCE AMERICANS TO GO
THROUGH ANOTHER FOUR YEARS OF
THE CLIENT THAT THE NEXT TWO
YEARS OR THEY TO SUFFER THROUGH,
AND THAT THEY GONNA DO THIS BY
HARPING ON TRUMPS SOCIAL MEDIA
POST, IN JANUARY 6, I THINK TO
BE SORELY DISAPPOINTED.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A GREAT SENATE
MAP IN 2024 AND A NUMBER OF
CANDIDATES WITH GREA